well I've studied acting and I've been
teaching it for a long time I've been
teaching it formally since 1973 and I've
taught in all kinds of places and
sometimes I've been required as would be
the case and not now in my career but
certainly early in my career on a
faculty of faculty you know a faculty
has to kind of achieve something as a
group and so a lot of times I've had to
teach very traditional things and very
traditional so I'm oh I know a lot about
the varieties of methods that there are
four approaching acting and I think the
best thing I heard about it one of my
teachers said that up you know you can't
really talk about acting directly
everything that we know to say is
couched in metaphors that's number one
sound like teaching medicine or teaching
architecture or even music because it
has to do with identity and we don't
really understand so much about it it's
not something we can touch or feel and
the changes of identities have never
been for example translated into music
like musical music is translated into
notes we haven't really translated what
we do into something that can be
constantly replicated with the result
that we can anticipate so there's
something about it that's a little
mysterious
Ethel mermans son actually was one of
the most powerful teachers that I had
and he said simply you know the actors
gift is the imagination and then one
very practical and gifted teacher said
you know acting is the ability that
believe that you are someone else so
people have all different ways of
talking about it but the first comment I
think is the most honest it's all
couched in metaphors and so I studied a
variety of methods people always make
fun of me in acting school because I was
always taking notes I was very
interested in what is this how is it
again that people can change before my
eyes and along the way of my studying
acting and also my teaching acting I
began to see that my students sounded a
lot alike and so I wanted to show them
that no human being talks like another
human being there are people who are
identical like you can have an identical
twin of your voice like there are people
who sound exactly like a sibling in the
tone of voice but nobody talks alike and
so I thought that one place to study
identity would be in the actual speech
of a given person
originally I was going around
interviewing people because I wanted to
teach something about that about
individuality as it is captured and in
the actual physical physiological
mechanism of making sounds we are
linguistic animals and then along the
lines of doing that I developed this
method through which I make plays which
is that I interview people I take
something that they said and then I
attempt to say exactly what they said
more than word-for-word utterance for
utterance because I have come to see
that it's in the way the utterances
themselves are manipulated that identity
comes forward so that's what I've been
studying and practicing for a very very
long time and I have to say the thing
that's unquenchable about me is
something I told you about earlier
really what I really really love to do
is to listen to people and listen to
stories and so over the past well i
guess i have to admit it's a little more
than 30 years now if i've been learning
anything it's that i've been learning
more and more about listening and I
never get tired of it never guitar
well the first thing is that it is it is
the actual making of language the actual
the in the present moment sound that a
person is making and how they're making
that sound that's where identity lives I
think I don't think it really lives in
like if you took my what I'm saying here
and you transcribed it I don't think
that's Anna deavere Smith but I think
that a series of sounds and movements
are anna deavere Smith in other words
the outward product of that and you know
your your your languages is close to
your breathing its close to your heart
and usually what I like to listen for is
the time when somebody says something in
an unusual way in that usually I talk to
people for about an hour and for example
if they're constantly using upward
inflections you know always speaking up
you know everything they say goes up
which younger people tend to do as I
heard a very accomplished judge say when
asked what advice you could give to
young women lawyers we're trying to make
it is don't do that because what does it
say to the judge if you come forward and
say your honor my client is not guilty
sounds like a question right so if
someone's talking all like that what I'm
going to listen for is the time that
they don't do that and that's what I
would start to study as a way of
characterizing them whereas I think a
professional mimic or an impressionist
would pick the thing they do the most
because that's what you an audience
could then identify as that person so an
impression is doing George Bush is going
to try to find the gestures and the you
know the intonations that he keeps using
over and over again but if i were to
study
I haven't really I'd look for when he
did something that wasn't what we've
seen
oh that's a really wonderful question
well i would say President Clinton for
example was I went to Washington and I
interviewed 520 people or more and I was
surprised that i would say of those
people the person Clinton was probably
among the five who had the most
musicality in their language in other
words in Washington I would say you
begin to find less and less expression
then you find in other places because
people are very careful about what they
say they're going to be judged for what
they say they could say the wrong thing
or say it the wrong way and never live
it down so they have as someone said
very eloquently what Thomas Jefferson
had which is that Thomas Jefferson could
never be found in verbal undress and so
I was and so that kind of verbal
dressing makes it harder to find music
in the language I'm trying to find the
time that people start to sing I call it
singing not actually you know Allah
Allah Allah but they really start to
open up rhythmically ah more than again
what's the text it's more about this
singing as I call it and I was surprised
the extent to which Clinton sang and the
other thing about Clinton that I enjoyed
was that he brought truth to something
that a linguist had actually told me
many years ago when I told her what I
was trying to do that is to say a form
of getting people to sing she had said
to me well I'm going to give you three
questions that can ensure that that that
will happen in the course of an hour if
you only have an hour to talk to people
and the three questions were have you
ever come close to death do you know the
circumstances of your birth and have you
ever been accused of something
didn't do now when i first started my
whole process which i call on the road a
search for american character all of my
plays are part of that series i
originally just SAT with people who i
met on the streets of new york and talk
to them about whatever they you know
they sold milk i talked about selling
milk or stick ball on the street in one
case or being a lifeguard at the Y I'd
sort of talked them about what they did
and then somewhere in the interview I'd
ask those three questions and lo and
behold every time I did people would
start this singing that I'm talking
about so when I finally got an interview
with President Clinton which wasn't easy
and was told that I would have ten
minutes alone with him in the Oval
Office I knew that I had to have a
question that would cause him to use the
entire ten minutes without me having to
say anything and the question I picked
was a version of one of those three
questions and it was mr. president do
you think you're being treated like a
common criminal which is a version of
heavy have been accused of something
that you didn't do he spoke for 35
minutes and as people you know coming to
the office mr. president you need to
rest your voice now okay bye so I was
really happy to see that something that
I learned you know you know 30 years
before not quite 30 27 years before I
met him actually was in good stead as
much as like oh you know I had
researchers I had everything in the
world to try to find the question I
should ask President Clinton
no I think you know I could never
remember whether it's in mark or John in
the Bible where Pontius Pilate is
supposedly seeking the truth about
Christ and you know and he says what is
truth you know is is it the truth you
know is the truth about this man or is
the truth about what will happen if I
make the wrong decision for example i
mean i'm quoting it very very badly here
but so i think that there probably is
not absolute truth but that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't seek to find facts it
doesn't mean that we should lie I think
the reason lying become so serious is
because to make a society to do things
to make buildings stand to do a heart
transplant to do anything that is
important we have to know that the
people around us are telling us things
that are real if not true we have to be
able to rely on the things that that we
are told as fact because we want to
believe that someone went and tried
something first and therefore learn to
that and they come and say well I've
been outside and it's raining today
right till we we learn to trust that
make decisions upon that fact so I don't
know if I'm really a seeker of truth in
terms of like is someone telling the
truth I think I'm really a student of um
I'm a student of human beings yeah I
think that's a
way of putting it then that I'm a seeker
of truth I'm a student of human beings
and their motivations and what causes
them to do what they say they're going
to do or what gets in the way of that
I think it's very hard in fact not to
see reality through the lens of your own
experience and I also think it's
difficult to put past experiences behind
us past experiences that become that
lens it's very hard to change that lens
and we don't have a version of a surgery
to help us do that I suppose we used to
think that things like psychotherapy
could help with it but now most people
go a psychopharmacologist and they're
less interested in the process of
telling their myths to someone who
should understand them and tearing those
myths apart when they don't help you
know one of my favorite artists is and
was Jacob Lawrence and I interviewed him
when he was quite old and he was talking
to me about growing up uptown in Harlem
and I was very interested in how
somebody who grew up uptown in Harlem
would have been able to mingle as well
as he did he was embraced by the
downtown art crowd that is to say the
white you know mainstream art crowd
embraced him his work and you know he
talked about how when he was a boy if a
white man were to walk on the street in
harlem or if he were to go downtown and
see white men walking on the street he
would automatically think to himself
that's a linter so to him every white
man was a potential injure just like you
know there were me would have been white
people who would believe that every
black man is a potential rapist or thief
well he thought every white man was a
potential winter and so I said to him I
said well how did you get over that and
said well you know he's are the simplest
thing but I had such resonance I thought
he said you know it's just like when
you're a child and you believe that
they're ghosts and goblins under the bed
and then one day you don't and so many
of us have different kinds of ghosts and
goblins we might think that we aren't so
attractive because somebody told us that
or we might think that we're very
attractive that we should be on display
because somebody told us that or we
might think that we have to lie if we've
done something wrong so we have these
things these past experiences that begin
to almost predict for us how we're going
to behave in any given situation and I
think it's very hard to recraft them and
I'm very interested in how people either
succeed and re crafting those things or
not
well actually in terms of listening to
stories of the listening part I think I
have less of a problem with that because
you know I've been doing it for a very
long time and you know as I say I sit
down with somebody and they could tell
me you know the ceiling is falling and
I'm mostly listening to how they said
the ceiling was falling and I'm missing
the point that the ceiling is falling so
I've really conditioned myself to go in
and listen for what I'm listening for
and so in that way I have to say I
really people always ask me sort of you
know how do I not judge people in blood
that is becomes irrelevant for me
because I'm listening to such a specific
thing when I go in I think what's harder
is how do I train myself out of my
habits in order to inhabit them and take
on on their habits and that's hard and
that comes from repetition it just has
to be you know my grandfather told me
when I was a kid if you say word often
enough it becomes you that's really you
know my acting technique in a sentence
is this belief that if I take someone's
words and repeat them over and over and
over and over and over again eventually
those words are going to hit my psyche
in a place that I understand who they
are really understand it which I
wouldn't understand from reading it or
hearing it the first time so I would say
the work that's really calls for that
has to do with reenacting more than
listening for the first time